hello welcome to
another night of chess on psychology
this is kind of
fun because we are combining
um chess on psychology with a little bit
more time so i would also like to
officially announce that
i'm caleb for today and for most of the
other wednesdays that you'll be here
i'll be caleb
caleb will be doors on tuesdays i
probably should have had a better
haircut
more caleb style but no i'm pretty
excited about
this um new ideas that we have
so we're gonna do a lot of uh
interesting opening middle game and the
game because i'm gonna have three hours
with you
on wednesdays so it's gonna be a lot of
fun
but the i think the most exciting part
for the viewers
is probably gonna be like that stitch
that we're gonna do from youtube to
twitch
in about two hours because we are gonna
have a lot of fun
because well you guys are gonna send me
your games that you played on
preferably leeches or chess.com also
acceptable but
preferably leeches because we're going
to work on leeches
so that's something that you guys are
going to be able to do and i'm quite
excited to be able to see your games on
there
within the next three hours you will
probably hear a lot of meows right now
gmp she's asleep on his throne
but this stray cat has been coming along
it is extremely cold in here
it's like snowing and i already hate
cold but when i go out it's so cold that
i'm wearing like a jacket holding a
blanket
and like anything you the only thing
you're gonna see from my face is just
like my eyes not even my eyebrows or
anything below the eyes just like i just
wanna it's so cold it's just it's
disgustingly cold
uh hopefully you are one of those lucky
people who likes colds and bees
able to actually be in cold i am not
so um last week
we talked i showed this idea that uh
jordan i believe played in najdorf with
queen d3
and i promise that i'll show uh more
games that i have done
in it um so i combined four of my games
in one because i kind of wanted to
get that um
like combination of different variations
that my opponents played
also i i hopefully am not gonna get not
getting cold but i've been a little
sneezy so if you hear sneezing
throughout the tonight the next three
hours i already apologize for that
um so i already gave you a heads up
about meows sneezes i have tea
water and um sparkly apple juice ready
so yeah i am ready to go
all right so um
i have my chat here too i think
everybody is doing well all right
so if you want more uh content
on this line we talked a lot about this
idea with queen d3
last week when jordan played it i played
this a lot in
16 and then i kind of like made a little
modifications i still play this idea but
it's a little bit more
um i want to say sophisticated as a
version
i don't just run with my queen
immediately
so i want to hear from the audience what
do you guys think what's going on so
what's white gonna do
what's what black gonna do
that is true actually there are about
four possums that
join uh behind my backyard
uh raccoon there has been a few few
instances of raccoon
um chelap has his own road to town caleb
is still doing road to 2000 and
um i believe he only changed the time uh
this
is just on psychology so like we
switched it from tuesday to
wednesday
yes i see that there is gonna be kind of
oh i'm so
sorry hoo man well there will be a
recording of it so
feel free to come by and look at it
later
yeah so a black wants to try and do this
e5 that is correct
um white ideally could have bishop g5 is
always a
cool idea i could start a zoo i just
don't really own any of these
animals except for kishi which is
super cute with snow he hates the snow
he tries to brave up and go out and like
he takes a little squirrel in the
backyard for like
a minute and then he starts meow meow
and comes back home
he's freezing i'm freezing i i
put my temperature in the house up to
82.
i am usually happy with like 75-76
so all right
um so i had four different lines happen
to me
one of them was knight c6 um there were
e5's that people did and
there is this idea with
knight d7 so
i lo i want to have these games i think
i lost one of them and i made a horrible
mistake on the other one
so um yeah you're gonna have such fun
time with this
let's probably um i would say let's
start from
the line that is kind of easier with
knight c6
so let's see why knight c6 is wrong
tommy i'm telling you here it's so cold
like when i walk on the floor
floor on my floors are super cold
steve that is not entirely true a lot of
people come here to see jm peachy
he graces us with his presence here and
there
he's been super cute all right so what
do you guys think
after this knight c6 should we try to
take that are we trying to develop this
bishop where do you think we're going
tommy i feel bad for me too it is very
cold here
i can't even begin to emphasize how
cold it is taking is possible but bishop
g5 makes the most sense because
where else am i going to go with this
bishop bishop e3 possible but it's not
really going the right direction
bishop g5 so now uh let's say
opponents oh well these are i'm assuming
most of these are kind of like uncharted
territory for most people
i don't think many people play this line
with white so
what do what do you think are some of
the good ideas for black to do
what should they do with this pieces
fun fact in us they don't really do
sparkly apple juice
so i make my own like i get apple juice
i get one of those like
sparkly whatevers i generally like the
ones that are called bubbly
they have like nice flavor too and i mix
them up together
i used to hate it when i was in europe
and i started kind of missing it
sparkly water makes it apple juice
when was this game this was a game of
mine that i played in 2015.
so yeah generally this idea with e6 to
try to free this bishop or something
with bishop d7 and then trying to free
the bishop
let's take a quick look at e6 now after
e6 um what do you want to do with your
king should we castle or should we try
to cast the short side
grateful yes i don't technically
carbonate it
apple just just apple juice is too sweet
kind of hurts my throat
so i kind of mix it up half and half
with carbonated water
it's good i like it
oh chess king you're trying to do a
hedgehog or a switch makeup
um yes it's not a bad idea
but how do you think why should continue
uh manish i agree queenside castle seems
to be going a little bit more
we were already prepared for it why not
also it brings another
lovely thing to e6 um
in the game my opponent played knight e5
it feels a little weird
yes we are showing why knight c6 is not
the most accurate
idea again there are different ways that
black could play this knight c6 is not
technically like
a bad move but it's definitely not the
best move
because you sometimes you might want to
try to do knight d7 sometimes
you don't exactly know where this knight
would belong so the fact that you try to
get it out that
soon is not really the best idea
so now what shall we do with this queen
the other problem that i have with cold
it's just some things that's weird i
don't think many people
experience this is that i get so cold
when i'm outside that i start shivering
and when i shiver i like my teeth cling
together lunge together whatever and
then i bite my
my mouth so i have like cold sores all
around it's a little painful
so if i speak weirdly or if i say weird
house there's another
heads up for you guys it's i hate cold
i definitely didn't not choose the right
states
for the weather coin g3 is interesting
um queen h3 might be also
another interesting idea because you're
not really having any of these
e5s so it's feels quite safe at the
moment
but queen g3 is the best idea you guys
are correct when g3 would make it a
little bit easier
my problem with queen g3 was
now what would you do after h6 where are
you gonna put this bishop
real i think um but yeah i i follow nazi
pakistan on
instagram so i kind of get a um so i see
her stories
yeah i know las vegas having a good
weather
when we're freezing here
see that's kind of the problem bishop
you're kind of
forced to do either bishop to e3
or some something weird like f4 i don't
think exactly
um i didn't exactly think about the idea
with f4 i would not really like this
bishop f4
knight h5 then what are you gonna do
you're kind of like kind of have to like
run away
and not g4 and it's kind of making it
really hard to protect this
also e5s are coming up so be very
careful
bishop f4 does not work but if h6
either bishop e3 or f4 works um
in the game i went by with queenie too
uh queen it is also perfectly fine but i
wish that i could also have this bishop
out so that's something that's a little
yeah it's a little uncertainty
so um black plays h6
bishop h4 g5 save the bishop
and queen c7 now white already has a
tiny bit
better position how can we continue
tiny bit better because of development
because of center
because there are so many different
things that we can start poking at
i see we have a few turkish people here
awesome
i love turkey i've been there a few
times
why are we running with the king to b1
nobody's attacking my king
oh i see f4 h4 i like those yeah
um taking might be a little premature
just because
you would have to move this knight and
it also opens up the bishop
so let's say you're playing knight b3
then b5 trying to come over here
also it's you kind of give your opponent
the chance
to start um
moving their pieces oh catalunya i i was
in catalonia i actually played
um i wasn't living around catalonia for
over
about a year i think one of the games
that i'm about to show
is one of the games that i actually lost
lol in monte carlo open to any
15. so yeah let's not take that
but i like the idea of h4 h4 is pretty
cool
if you were to be smart and play g4
now i could try and do like f4
if i'm poison no problem f4 is still
coming up
um let's see so in the game black simply
played rook g8 i
took and now what do you think we should
do i remember
this move took me forever to try and
figure out it was just
so unnatural to me at least
i it wasn't the best move anyways like
king b1 would have been a good idea
but i knew that my opponent wanted to
try and play like b5 so i was trying to
come up with something to deal with that
king b1 is the best idea but
i did not do that
oh no no a4 is just like oh boy
actually it's not that bad but it it it
creates a lot of uh
poking situations
whoa chess king yes that's what i did i
played knight f3
but it looks good but it just it created
a lot of problems down the line as well
oh great wolf
good observation
um so after knight f3
i believe knight d7 was played now what
do you guys think
is 97 a good idea
[Music]
ah dead enough here funny i wonder how
you
handled yourself with dennis's lectures
the idea behind knight f3 um the idea
behind knight f3 was well to be honest
uh this knight here is not really doing
anything
and i wanted to open up my rook and this
is a very annoying night so if i could
kind of
move this knight then my bishop could
actually be attacking some stuff
so why not knight f3 trying to poke this
knight a little
b5 would be the best idea and then we
would probably play it with a3 to stop
b4
something they probably made bishop b7
tried to maybe king b
won it a little this is still
whitehall's advantage but it's not
um it's not super super duper sufficient
it's um it's just one of those type of
a little weird advantages that you never
know what's gonna happen
hold on what's gonna happen ah knight b5
queen's defending here sorry i'm going
off tangent
but yeah that was kind of the point b5
would be the best try
um
so what about after knight d7 what
should we do
i like white's position mainly because
it's bringing so much pressure to my
opponent
oh do-over style no no that guy is a
monster
he she's the way he know i can't do that
so we're trying to figure out what to do
for whites uh dru cage
seven well we're trying to go with this
truck
mike what's your next move
it looks very tempting but i just don't
get what's your next move
what if i just just bishop e7
now this is i mean honestly record seven
would also be a good idea
but i was just sick of all the threats
and i was just like ah let's just play
the screen b1
well after king b1 he just played b5
now what i feel like black was a little
bit late to the party
uh
um a3 not yet
well black's uh black is kind of
threatening to
you know poke a little here and there
but it's not that serious of a threat
well the thing is um
my problem with a3 is this knight c4
trading everything on e5 so that's the
thing i wanted you to take here i don't
want to take
so how can we try and um
not exactly force but kind of force
black into taking my knight
well you guys think i'll give you
another mini update on
university life so we got this very
interesting scary email yesterday from
like the dean's office everybody got
that because
people are not being very cautious with
the social distancing measurements and
i feel like even i'm slacking a little
bit just because well it depends like if
i'm if i'm with the same group of people
that i meet on daily basis
then yeah i feel like i'm slacking a
little so we got that email
the quite frankly telling us either
do it right or we're going to send
everyone home so it was interesting
if there are other people here in the
university who are
like in the university not just online
and yeah if you want to share how it's
going with you
i have not gotten the vaccine yet i am
going to be taking you to general
population because i'm not high risk
rookish five good job everybody yeah
you're kind of trying to push this
right nothing is not necessarily the
best move that the engine it does
like engine kinda is digging this idea
with queenie one
it's a little hard for me to um
wrap my head around it i i wouldn't
really exactly like to do this queen e1
it looks interesting but then what
so yeah i'm not i'm not so big on this
idea
um taking on e5 is another thing that
the computer suggests and if you take
with pawn
then like queen d2 but i was really
hopeful that i could pull this rickish
five off
there's not much wrong about it the only
problem is if b4
now after knight a4 bishop b7 like
bishop c6 coming up so you have to be
very careful with this
um i am at saint louis university
so okay knight takes f3
queen takes f3 and here he
also made another inaccuracy and played
knight e5
now first of all what do you think is
wrong with knight e5
um georgie we are not at that huge
sacrificial level just yet
we're getting there though
oh i'm glad their twitter stuff going on
i probably should do more stuff on
twitter i don't do anything on twitter
i do more on instagram which reminds me
i wanted to post about this class i
forgot
whoops
yeah because we can take it so let's say
um
you take it take back
and then where do you want to go also
also before we
go deeper what do you think black should
have done now
because it's i mean it seems like it's
going well
but we should still be able to try and
think about what's the
uh opponent's best move
also i'm not sure what's going on
upstairs they're being very
loud i guess they're watching tv with
full blast
uh
i wish i had like a broom that i would
just do that so they would stop making
noise
oh they're they're sweet girls though
never mind
i feel like if i told them uh
less noise they would be very
understanding the problem is like i
can't do that every day i can't
every i can't just go and knock on their
door every day and be like yo
slow down
no not necessarily bishop b5 more on g4
because there are no queen f6 and if you
were to play queen f4
now b4 so the idea is that where
black should try to play as aggressive
as he can
but that doesn't mean that he should um
not play good moves
so the the idea is that
black should play aggressive that's it
yep um so in the game knight t5 is not
aggressive enough because i just take it
and
now i actually have two different
super cool oops two different super cool
ideas what do you guys think
are the best moves
i don't think it's about them being
considerate it's more of
so the buildings that i live in i live
in
um they're very good buildings but like
i have like an apartment that are
supposedly dorms
on campus so that's i have a pretty good
thing going
but the problem is that
it's so old that the walls are so ten
i feel like when i sneeze everybody can
hear me
so yeah that's kind of the little issue
that we have
so
ah queen f6 interesting but no
rook h7 i like it might be five words
considering
so tell me what do you think about
knight b5 is a good idea
the problem with queen f6 is that it's a
little out of place because
it's just bishop e7 and then there's g4
and then like
your queen gets all the way kicked
around we don't want you don't want
our queen to get kicked around so if we
could do this queen of six would be
pretty cool
cool
taking on v5 definitely cool idea r7
cool idea does anybody want to give me a
little bit more on either of them
oh getting an error on my computer nope
no computer ever needed
ah tracy you're here hello
no uh yes actually knight b5 is a good
idea
because if take take no [ __ ] of d7
so king e7 is the only move now what do
you think we should do
i i was kind of stuck on this position
and i didn't
do this in the game i wish i did i
played drug h7
surprisingly rook h7 is actually a
better move
so i'm not super worried about my
choice of playing rick h7
but what do you think about this move
rook is seven actually a good idea but
you know what's really funny is i wish i
could do queen a3 how can i try and give
check in that diagonal
oh yeah peter peterson probably that was
tracy on twitter
a4 thank you everybody
now you want to go to a3 and it's
very interesting because let's say
something like
let's say you played rook a6 to try and
cover up first of all i can eat that
second of all even rook h7 again trying
to poke left and right
uh you can take over there ah
come on give that check
king f6 queen e3 kind of looks cool too
no it's a very good position oh
interesting not tracy wow
so knight b5 would have been a good idea
i went for rick h7
also very healthy after brick h7 bishop
g7 now how
should we continue our attack
to be honest after a4 uh white is like
plus
almost three so it's not exactly i mean
most of the things that white does leads
to winning
so i'm not really worried even if you
don't get queen a3
because all of our pieces are super
active
so
anybody want to tell me what to do now
uh-oh hey hold on i see i see people who
are in this
league chess.org uh our study
good get out guys this is my study i'll
share the link at the end
wolf bye bye go away
yeah this is fun i'm gonna share it
later
don't don't don't take over
ah
surprisingly yes i played this idea with
queen h3 actually it's a good idea
not the best idea the best idea would be
take
i know very surprising if take
now just night takes and another fun
time
things are happening
um the super thing is now what should
whites do why does this one only move
what do you think white should do to win
i'm reading the chat i'm reading a chat
nope
there's only one move
nope nope nope i'm reading the chat
together suggesting some queen size some
knight d6
nope
good job thank you arthur queen c3
trying to go for
c7 super cool right
if king goes to f8 it's so fun
because you can't even play queen c7
you've sacrificed
already but you're gonna go to this end
game because you have rook t8 coming up
see so super cool right
and this is super winning you move the
bishop i can just take that
and then give another check take that
take that i'm gonna eat it all
so that was bishop b5
i simply went for a queen h3 queen h5
would also be a good idea
i decided to go queen h3 i don't know
why i think i chickened out just a
little bit
but my position is still pretty quite
pretty because now after queen e7
there was a mini thing to do here
now what do you think white to move is
there a mini
i don't know tactic here your opponent
king is in the middle of the board
development is quite miserable
yes nice take take check and work d8
this was quite fun because if i'm not
mistaken my opponent was
uh he was not weak he was like
20 almost like 2300
so it was a good game i liked it
all right uh let's look at another game
because i want to try
and um squeeze in another game
in this line in there
preferably something that i was a good
game
all right so back to the initial
position
after queen d3 we talked about knight c6
now let's talk about e5 what what should
we do with this knight
oh it didn't change the name let me see
if i can actually change the name
because
this is a different opponent
whoops no stop showing the moves bad
computer
sorry guys it's
okay ah change the name
uh all right so we talked about e5
and now what
accidentally showed it but knight f5 is
a good idea
because take take now you have this
bishop g5 coming
nice different variations coming and
also like the pawns are very everything
is super active so knight f5 is kind of
a fun move
so now now that white's gonna do all
these different ideas how do you think
black can try to stop some of them
not sure what's going on upstairs
there's a lot of dropping
a lot of walking
floorboard squeaks ugh
nope well d5 is possible but the
bishop g5 threat is still there so
bishop g5 maybe try to eliminate
that
yep
h6 is also a pretty decent idea because
you simply try to stop bishop g5
now bishop uh i played bishop e3 bishop
e3 sounded like a
more legit way to go trying to
create some poking material
knight c6 now should you do long castle
to be honest uh the answer should be
immediate yes
because if you weren't going to play
long castle then your queen d3 was a
pretty um
interesting way to play this
as you can see i'm getting colder and
colder by the minute
it is super cold
i guess it's time for tina
ah this is one of my most favorite cups
keeps it so warm
uh why do we need a3 why can't we just
castle now
i mean i like i don't exactly like the
idea of a3 because it's always
going to be a threat also what would you
do after d5
because if your opponent tried to play
d5 now you have long castle if d4
it doesn't really make much sense
because well like this is pinned
so you would have like f4 and let's say
knight here you can take over here
if you were attacking the knight so um
that makes more sense
but i don't really understand why you
would want to play a3 right now
so uh yeah let's do the castle now if
you play d5
well i can just take it because i'm
attacking it to three you're only
doing it with two so
there we go oh the idea of
knight d5 um
it would be interesting but there is
this nasty queen a5 here and then if you
come back then there's d5 coming up with
d4
bishop d2 and then like the center
immediately collapses
oh yeah
after castle we could try for knight d5
so
in the game um my opponent went for
queen a5 to stop my knights d5s
now what do you think we should do
i like the idea of moving the king to a
safer location
now if is still doable too
i went for a slightly different idea
i went for e3 and i'm not very proud of
this a3
uh just like king b1 would have been
just
all right enough but a3 um
i didn't exactly like it because i
wasn't sure
what are you going to do if you had
already castled whoops
if you had already castles sure so uh
um after eighteen my opponents played
castle so it made a little bit more
sense
now question for oh stop moving around
mouse
now question for you guys what do you
think we should do with our position
so you see that we have somewhat of a
harmony going on
you have to be careful because the
center is about to be
opened up
thank you thank you i think um 18
yes f4 you want to open up the center
so do i i have two bishops so i really
do
um now after take take and now this is a
weak pawn
awesome d5 so what should we do with
this pawn
how can we try to make the best of it as
white
in this position
um 95 i wish but there
are three defenders
so that's one of the thing king b1 kind
of works
quite interestingly in a lot of these
positions
like i don't really have a valid reason
why i should think about this king b1
but k1 is a good choice mainly because
what else would you try to do
now what's that what can black do try
and play d4
all right well i can just do 94.
i guess the good thing is they're not
going to be many checks around
defending the king side a little i like
this idea
but i'm still a little uncomfortable to
think like that's the first thing that
would come to mind
so now in the game
i played bishop d2 bishop d2 was not a
good idea
can you tell me what's wrong with bishop
d2
yeah taking that whoa that sacrifice
that's so strong
take take king b1
knight b4 now you would have to do like
a queen d4
knight e4 this is super scary
why to be lucky to get away with this
um yeah everything i get f6
g6 apparently this is such a such a
sad slash weird position
what if you just take then take that's a
check
yeah this is just sad
all right so um
that's why bishop d2 was not a good idea
i should have just tried with king b1
i went for bishop d2 i think i was a
little too optimistic that was the
problem
um and he also missed it he played d4
now what do you think we should do after
d4
matt king i agree with you this is not
the ideal position
but what do you think we're not gonna
get ideal position every single game
i agree i have been up a little too
early
so don't invite me to sleep i'm a little
sleepy already
especially looking at gmpg up there
sleepy oh
he's just stressed so cute
um that's the thing with knight b1
i don't really want to do this knight b1
it feels like my knight is trapping
itself
so let's just go for knight e4
and now in the game my opponents played
queen d5
now let's take that
and all right so my opponent want to
give me a checkmate in one
what should i do
b3 b trainer checkmate oh two different
types of checkmates
ah c3 it's unnecessary to play c3 that's
a little too extra
c4 now i can guess behind but i also
like the idea of just
moving this bishop what about bishop f4
what's wrong with that
why do you guys want to give up stuff
bishop c3 just takes
and checkmate's still coming up and
also this rook is defending d2 guys be
careful
don't just make don't just make moves
i agree with you f4 yes that's the move
i played in the game too
now this is a very critical position
what should black do black has only one
move that
holds everything else loses
that's the thing do we how much do we
care about this b2 pawn
no the problem isn't that black should
resign the problems that black
got a little greedy instead of taking on
f6 here
so i would play like queen b3 take take
it would play this end game this would
most likely end in a draw
bishop d6 take take
something on d3 maybe b4
instead of going for this black got
greedy
and he thought he's winning he
mis-evaluated the position that's
why i always tell especially my camp
kids my beginners intermediates
always always always evaluates because
evaluation helps to figure out
how you're doing if you're trying to
play for win if you're trying to play
for draw
it gives you like that objective
perspective on how it's
what's your position doing especially
because
in order to evaluate you have to
actually look at the whole board you
have to look at the big picture
you have to think about who has more
material whose king is safer who has
better center who has better peace
activity who has better space
uh pawn structure two bishops i can keep
listening
so that's why you should think about is
this actually winning for black or am i
actually over like sitting here dreaming
so queen a1 was played this is a
horrible move king d2
he took and i just saved my knight
because if you evaluate it you would
realize that well i have one extra night
and there's no severe threats going on
to
white's king so white has the luxury of
saving this knight
uh black took bishop e3
and just continued with this idea i was
just like you know what i'm gonna put my
king in the safe
place just develop
uh instead of knight d2 i could have
just simply played bishop e2
that would have been much easier but i
don't make my life easier
so ha i went for knight d2
knight b3 now trying to trap your queen
too maybe
and now
what should wise do
ah
wait i did something wrong did something
terribly wrong
whoops that was supposed to be my mini
ad
i clicked on it too early i apologize
see i shouldn't be touching anything on
obs obs is for big boys
i shouldn't touch was this in your time
in austrian bundesliga
no this was it was quite funny i played
um in neither memorial
2015 in poland this was in poland
no nobody's taking over my pc i was
trying to just look to make sure that my
uh like break ad
was here um and it was but i
accidentally
clicked on its eye whoops
yeah okay one let's go let's go eat the
queen okay one
queen b2 and let's just eat that
to be honest uh that's like the easiest
way to win
the f6 is also possible i saw some
suggestion like that but the problem is
that
now this is another thing to be worried
about it's not such a big deal
because obviously white has so much more
material
but it's requisite such a cool idea
now if you take whoops if you take
this is made in three moves
another check look how this pawn is
doing on such an awesome job
this is checkmate next move woof
um so that's kind of a full idea that i
had
and my opponents played this queen bee
one
and i was just like sure i'm just going
to come attack your queen again
and then i just developed and now i want
to do like another rook we want to i
just ate that pawn
to be fair i could have been more
aggressive and just like
eating here i don't know what i was
afraid of i think maybe queenie one or
something
really did start to bug me so i didn't
want to deal with that
but that was just like an easier idea
too i just kicked this away
developed and finally
won again like bishop f3 would have been
easier but it's really hard to find
all best moves in a game that is
has so much different ideas sometimes
it's all forced
if you go there you want to give a fork
yeah those i understand but it's
really hard to try and figure out all
best moves in a single game
so um i gave this check
to kirk b1 kaba going for that
too and that's checkmate
in three moves uh oh wait
where are okays we are gonna transition
to the end game class pretty soon
so be ready for that coming up
i'm quite excited about that so uh this
endgame class is something that
i've been doing for quite a while
on our um what's this called
our twitch channel so it's a little it's
it's a little
interesting that
i'm gonna be doing this right away
when is analyze my game it's the one
right after this so
um most likely there we're still
deciding on a lot of things but most
likely from
next week we're not gonna be doing end
games on wednesdays
but instead we're gonna be doing the
same end games on fridays
i've been doing on twitch but for today
we're going to keep in with the end game
and if you like it make sure to join me
on twitch for
friday all right so um
let me show you the first puzzle
it's kind of a fun puzzle also let me
double check if my ad works because if
it does work i would love to
grab t my t went cold i forgot to
put on the lid um let me double check if
this
works does my ad work yes my ad works so
enjoy janine for about a minute i am
just gonna grab hot water
hello we are back great
no it wasn't a cattle and also this tea
is
actually russian i like my green fie
teal
green filled tea there we go they're
great
no class not dismissed everybody i hope
you got you got up did a little stretch
it wasn't that long maybe a minute two
so ah i was gonna ask if this is winning
or losing
this is already showing this is winning
this is sad
let me crop this part out
all right it wasn't just tea there's a
i'll tell you little secrets
so i don't know how many of you here are
in the us
but first of all starbucks in the u.s
is not that good that's not a secret
uh if you ever been to a starbucks
anywhere else
this is so like
starbucks in u.s is so just doesn't have
any cakes
their merchandise is so
basic if you've been compared to
anywhere else
so i i used to love the like the awesome
cake slices in europe
ah it is white to move yes i'm just
gushing over starbucks a little
or dissing starbucks i don't know so but
the one thing that i do like about
starbucks
especially in us is that they have this
really awesome um
bread loves that like with like i don't
know what
is it it's like banana loaf red velvet
loaf like it's not exact cake because
to me cake is that like cold like
cold-ish cake with like
cream and all those
good stuff um but also i'm not
very big on valentine's like i don't
really get the whole concept of
here is like 100 roses 400 things that
i've known you
here is all this like hard chocolates
that like if it just you show me
chocolates you give me a box of
chocolate i'm not gonna hold on to it it
will be done before the midnight
so that's another problem um
but um i'm i guess i'm dissing valentine
but i'm praising starbucks because
around valentine's they bring this
really fun
bread loaf red velvet loaf so if any of
you are in usnr
um have starbucks close by stop by and
ask for their
red velvet loaf oh it's so good so i was
also
kind of um munching a little on that it
was good
it was staring here sitting here staring
at me
and i did not want to uh i needed the
moments with my cake alone
so yes surprise everybody
black does not win it's
very i'm so glad none of you got this
right
no white is winning that's so fun white
is winning
chess king thank you
it's so funny i'm gonna give you guys a
minute for the reactions to come in
uh stefan i don't think so i
know that would be a little um
yeah i wouldn't be able to afford that
it would be a little
too much for a slice of cake no no no no
guys guys we don't we don't want to
we don't want draw we want to win i
don't want to play c7 and do perpetual
c7 is for
it's no no no no c7 you're right this is
perpetual good i
c7 is perpetual so we should start with
a7 and we want to win this
if you don't take i'm gonna play c7 c8
so you have to take and now king b7
you gotta move this rook let's say you
go wherever
just queen check boom bye bye
and i'll just keep moving my king closer
where is my cat he just woke up
as we speak and he's grooming
i could try and give ben simon a mini
heart attack by moving the laptop to
show the cat
alright what do you guys think about
this position
ah john thank you that's very sweet of
you to say so i hope to see you again on
our streams
i'm here on wednesdays and fridays i
think friday is just twitch but
yeah please join us
steve nort ah i
i'm a little ashamed of my starbucks
spendings
it is white to move i apologize if there
is black to move i will say that i will
flip the board
if i don't say anything then it's white
to move
let's see oh the cat just went back to
sleep
i don't think you guys will see much of
him i apologize ben
for this small disruption
whoa ah there he is
well at least we got his attention
so how horrible was that
should i never do that again or
well that's for you guys to tell me
are we winning are we losing what are we
fighting for
oh i'm glad i at least got few cutes
it was quite cute i did not expect him
to pay attention to us
see the problem with king e6 is rookie
chains
and now this rook is freed
i see a mr kakawu in my
in my studies
guys i'm going to call you out get out
get out of my studies
oh i'll send this to you everybody after
the after the stream
knight b6 might be
you tell me if knight b6 he's probably
gonna take it because you're threatening
checkmates right
so knights v6 take yes good job good
finding on zugzwang
there was this other thing with e6 as
well careful not to get checked on to
that
and if e6 just king of f6 we still want
to give checkmate
if you take it just king f7 i still want
to eat your rook
so that's another way of trying to go
about it
but e6 took me a minute but i'm glad you
guys found this that was an easy
i'm somewhat uh easy um
i couldn't come up with the award yeah
this was great no good
so uh this is so yay
we got a crazy position
so this is the type of um
puzzles that we usually do on
fridays on twitch so please make sure to
join us on friday for twitch on
king and pawn warfare it's 5 p.m central
time
right now it's like 7 15 16.
exactly grateful that's the type of
puzzles
so i give you some puzzles to give you a
mini headache
and after the headache is there we find
ways to resolve it
and then we do a few easy ones and then
on fridays on twitch
we wrap it up with few good old um
tactics more middle games
but yeah so uh today i'm doing
more of like an advertisement for my
friday lesson so please join me on
friday so we can enjoy these more
all right so i see some ideas
i see like f4 coming up i see what else
c4 idea
let's let's try to let's try to think
first of all
checks then takes i love this position
because first of all this is not real
life if anybody was wondering this is
not real life
but it's so funny because the board is
just so
um symmetrical it's like imagine if
there was a line and nope not here ah
if there was a line in the between e and
d
file it would say such a symmetrical
thing for black and
white
there are a lot of checks there's this
eating that eating that chick
that chick um
yeah d6 200 36 not really worth it
though
oh too hot
g5
no not really the problem with drug g5
is
check you move it you're gonna get
checkmated soon
where else can i give check this one
check out there
can't go anywhere haha
yeah be very careful
what about drug takes b5
the problem is king ghost c4 and you're
kind of out of checks
there's still a bunch of stuff happening
with that bishop there's still that
threat up checkmate here
so you can't really it's really hard to
try and actually make this into a fair
game
so king dietrich is also an interesting
idea
because now after king d3 you want to
start poking with checks
if check now you take back
king e5 and now you can take over here
again check
this is doable this is a this is one way
to go
yes thank you grateful for asking what
about king d3
if something like rook c7 nah that's a
bad move because c4
i'll get to eat this guy
i'll get to eat this guy this is also
falling yeah this is just too cool
uh so the best move what do you think is
the best move after king d3
to be fair f4 is very interesting
after king c4 it's just one move
that you have if you can find this idea
after king c4 you're saved
but it's quite hard to find it
so only move what's your only move
anybody ouch
nope not light f3
nope not king d2
this is kind of fun for me
john yeah rook c6
crazy right take boom
can you see five knights a4 perpetual
it's crazy i agree
this is so weird though and it's kind of
fun because you have to do this
so unless you see this uh idea with f4
and then rook c6 then you shouldn't do
this f4 because rook c6 is the only move
if you did say it were perfect you got
your draw
um if not king d3 is also pretty doable
if king e5 just king e3 just gonna
follow the king
[Music]
um steve
no this is not from one of my games i
wish
no this is a uh this is something just
to get you guys to go
yeah this is this is not a real life
game this is just to
get that reaction out of you guys all
right
so something a little less crazy can
white holds this
i'm annie wait wait could you remind me
where do you live
i know you've been with us for our
streams pretty much
forever but could you just remind me one
more time where do you live
i want to say norway i'm probably dead
wrong
of course a little bit is white to move
oh all armania
wait
i still have a quarter of c2s you guys
are correct trixty too
because you can't take it it's a draw if
you do if you don't take it now i'm just
gonna
move my kink here and there you can't
bring your king voila draw
good this one was somewhat easier
compared to the crazy one
let's go back to our crazy puzzles
that's what i was thinking oh man farsi
we call germany almond
so i i was kind of under the assumption
that armania would be germany anyways
not entirely sure though
it is white to move yes
thank you i'm annie
uh axel what have you been waiting for
hmm queen a5 now
is that free pawn because are there some
you know
cool like i'm gonna make a queen you
take it knight c2 type of deal
that's kind of the problem the problem
is that
if you try if it was black to move black
and just eat your queen so it's
white if you play like queen b2 i make a
queen
if you take it just knight c2 and now
white is losing
so what should we do
that's the problem with any move that
you do anywhere you go trying to stop
this there's this knight c2
you take here oh you take i
take
you take i make a queen check you take
i'll give check and i'll take this
same thing you go to c3 i'm gonna do the
exact same
thing
now the question is do i have to take it
over here do i have to take this
same with queen coming to b2 or c3
you'll make queen do i have to take it
because it's not for check
ah i see zippole is sharpening the
stalemate ideas
where how can we do that
hi manny i think you're thinking about
this quite nicely
where are you going are you going queen
to c3 are you going to
b2 where are you going
careful queenie wonders knight c2
well that's kind of the problem queen c3
yes if
queen queen king goes to e4 giving you
check
and if you take still mate king can't
really go anywhere
right but that's not the point the point
is what if knight
f5 check now when you move the king and
now i just
wait it out and next i want to make a
queen this is so weird because this is
still better for black white is
still struggling to get a draw
okay moves i'll save this this is so
weird that's why
if you could find a more
more forceful line for white
that would be perfect perfect
how my cold sore is beginning to really
bug me
all right i see that chad is suggesting
queen c5
no guys queen see if i might just make a
queen
no no no no no no no no
what would you do to solve this puzzle
you should try to figure out the most
forceful lines
so queen c3 would be pretty forceful but
there's this knight f5 so if you can't
find anything
uh better than than um
queen c3 then you should do that but
what about queen b2
what if queen that's the that's the main
concerning thing what should we do
i agree there should be some still mate
somewhere
that's the problem king e4 doesn't
really work anymore because
there is going to be as news with it
like a square for our king to go
or to take so careful
how can you still do the same idea all
right great great
king c5 from barcelona i love it i see a
lot of kings e5 coming in so good
giving check and the
attacking queen take notices still meet
so
how to approach it is not much different
than finding queen c3 so first off let
me tell you
the things that we can eliminate this
check
uh sorry queen a3 and queen e1
immediately eliminated because of knight
c2 check
fork so let's do that first no need to
no need to be too fancy i'm going to
eliminate these two
first things then we can try to figure
out so
then we have only like three candidate
moves left going here
there and take all of them have the same
problem
of becoming queen on knight c2 because
of the geometry of
how our pieces are placed so queen a5 we
can also pretty
quickly say no to it because it's
forcing us to take
but we don't want to take so
now we're so that's also not now we're
stuck between this and that
queen b2 knight f5 doesn't really work
anymore because i get to eat this pawn
because my queen is not on c3 it's
actually attacking this pawn
that's a huge difference um
so then when you start thinking about it
you think about two different queen c3
or queen b2 and
you're gonna land on one of them um
there is a high chance that a lot of
people would make a mistake between
queen c3 and queen b2
well and that's just you would have to
be very
good at thinking about what does my
opponent want to do
parts of it so yeah
kind of scary right
what about this one this one is a little
less crazy
and when i say a little less i mean okay
still pretty crazy but just a little bit
less
um it is wise to move
i'm annie i agree with you
also let me make a little bit of
adjustments to my setup so i don't have
to
give myself a neck issue
all right i brought to i've had a little
closer
maybe a little too close can't really
see
all right guys he's on bishop b5 some a
lot of knight c5s
um all right so first of all what is
wrong with knight c5
any happy volunteers tell me what is
wrong with knights going to c5
okay i see that my c5 is coming along
because of knight c3
losing that guy
problem with bishop b5 similarly losing
that careful terrible it's a very sneaky
night
but it's not that it's only sneaky it's
also taking away
two of these squares away from our king
so let's face it your position sucks
you're gonna lose one of your
possessions uh pretty cool pieces
so in order to try and save that
we should try to um
come up with an idea to not
how can i say to that saying it let's
come with an idea that
might uh use the idea of still mates
there you go i gave you as much a hint
as i possibly could without giving you
the move
um no
king d3 just uh he just takes it over
here
well actually king e3 uh first of all he
just blocks this
with king d3 i'll just give check next i
want to eat here
no your king here is doing alright
no need to dance with the king
darth yes bishop d7 good
because now if you take it no i'll just
give check you take stalemate boom
all right nice bishop design was an only
move yeah
riley that would be great if we could
but that's this knight c3 is the problem
yeah these are cool puzzles right make
sure to join me on
friday 5-7 central time on twitch for
more
sounded like a psa
why to move can we win this
oh she's being shoot she's like he's
sleeping but his hand is kind of hanging
but i gave him a little high five
all right i see the idea of bishop h5
check i like that
that's not the strongest what do you
think is the strongest
which i wish mine was like the second
best move
hi manny um
if both sides play their best yes but
most of the time rook and bishop vs
strokes somebody messes up
so makes it a little harder to
there's a d6 jesus no no no let's not
give up our pieces
i like my pieces
so um
careful if you're suggesting bishop c2
which should be two there's rook g3
careful with that
okay bishop h5 is doable but the issue
with bishop h5
is not exactly issue but it's not
it's not as vital anymore
because black is just gonna try and eat
like give up the rook for a bishop and
pond then it's a drop
but we're trying to push for a win
it's so fun nobody's seeing it i love it
so it's not bishop c2 because bishop c2
take king f2 uh rook can go to g4
see that's the problem brooke gets to go
to g4
we don't want rook g4 ah
does that give you an idea
so we don't want rook going to g4
so if we don't want rook going to g4
yes bishop e2 now if you were to take it
just king f2 no rook g4 you can't really
go to g8 because i have bishop c4 you
can't really go to g6
because i have bishop h5 you can't
really go well you could go to g5 it
doesn't really help you
because you can't really go to b5
let's see what else can't you do you
can't really go to b3
because i'll have bishop c4
so yeah kind of cool right
i agree these are crazy puzzles i i
never said they're not
i gave you a full fair heads up they are
crazy puzzles
all right if there are any questions on
this let me know
and if not let's continue with our
causal right now this one it's still
white to move
wait wait
ah yes so
remember this puzzle
there's like a small difference between
this one and this one and that's the
pawn
structure remember and they also are
queen is under attack
so what about this can um
can we make this work a lawyer slot
that's not that's that's kind of almost
almost the same thing but not exactly
so i want you guys to take a quick look
at it and see if
you can still do the same things
uh-uh queen b2
yes see b4 is not covered there are a
lot of differences
e4 is not covered there's no pawn on f5
there's no pawn on g4 so f3 is not
covered
i hate to take the record to you guys
there's only
one move that holds the draw anything
else and you
lose
queen a5 see that's not again the
problem
i'll make a queen with check you have to
take it oh no just knight c2
so not queen a5
nope playing b2 doesn't work because i
can now make a bishop
that's the fun part because if i were to
make a queen
then yes king c5 you have to take draw
but i get to make a bishop
crazy right you take check boom
you don't take uh you move the king
you lose your queen that doesn't you
shouldn't do that
that's why it's not queen b2 because
there's a difference there's that's
making a bishop
no that was it that was a little
different we can't go back to the last
the previous one and say why making a
bishop wouldn't work
yes before square is not covered yeah
also also nothing is attacking my b4
so
i'm not forced to make moves with my
queen right now
am i
interesting idea with king e4 but the
problem is check
also what if i just make a queen then
what do you do
kind of curious
here
okay so i agree this doesn't work too
all right great thank you i'm annie
king c5 is the best one because now if
you were to make a queen
now i do queen beetle it was just like a
small change
in the move order good thank you thank
you for your
participation awesome um
now in the previous one there was a
question about
what if he played queen b2 and you made
a bishop well no problem i'll just take
it
uh whoops sorry no problem i'll just
move it whoops
sorry again because this pawn is
protecting on
b4 if you take it as a draw but here you
it's not
if i played uh queen b2 you made a
bishop
i mean with my king you would just take
it there is no pawn over here to defend
the square so it's within to be a still
means
all righty now this is
again the same thing just a tiny bit
different the pawns are a little
different
now what can can we still do can we
still get a draw in this
i like torturing you with this puzzle
hold on let me try my evil luck
i can't i try
i don't have an evil laugh i have a very
dead stare deadly stare
but with that's the cute cat i can't
have anything besides all
he's being so cute it's like his hand is
out there for a mini high five
this is so cool it's just how is this a
draw wise etc i love it
this is so cool what website am i using
leeches
it's so fun because this time
surprisingly bishop c5 does not work
because you don't have to push to make a
queen you can just play like a
bishop f7 and defend your pawn
that's why it's so weird previous one
you could play well after you played
king c5 there was no bishop f7
so what about this one oh hi john
glad to have you with us
nope queen a5 queen i5 is the one
constant
no in all of these puzzles because you
just
have to take it and as you guys saw in
previous puzzles
we don't want to be forced into taking
that thing
on a31 bishop queen whatever it becomes
so
yes now let's go with queen c3 good good
emperor good
improvisation if you make queen just
kinky for you take it
still meet if you don't
take it if you make like a a bishop
now i'll just go king c5 see fun stuff
if you take it now my this diagonal is
taken care of i get it so that's a
little um
it's a little crazy but these are good
puzzles it says like
at least this like pack of three that we
just did it helps you try to visualize
the little
differences that there are so it's good
you
should do it it's kind of level three i
agree yeah
um one thing to be careful is queen b1
doesn't work because b1
sorry a1 makes it into a bishop
um king e4 too early doesn't work
there's bishop c6 all right
let's do one more and then we're gonna
go switch to twitch
kind of been wanting to say that switch
to twitch this one is a good one i want
to end on a good high note
so make sure to send us
um so to send me actually
your games on twitch so have it ready
i'm gonna uh after this one i'm gonna
need about
five to seven minutes to make a switch
between youtube to twitch
make the switch from youtube i can't
make that rhyme
as well as i wanted to so um
make sure to do that come on twitch
follow us subscribe
do all those fun stuff i
i'm hoping that the little functional
zombie that we talked about yesterday
is gonna be working so yes please
join us then and why am i not on twitch
tv right now because we are on youtube
anybody has suggestions for this puzzle
uh any of that is a good question i'm
sure
one of our moderators can help with that
i can also uh pull up twitch from
here but probably take me a minute
maybe less
uh where is my
twitch whoops
why am i checking myself out on twitch
um share via
a copy and then i can do this
yes so i just send a link for our twitch
yeah that's one of the things not many
of the youtube subscribers
do twitch which is a little weird but
we're gonna do the game analysis there
so it's more of a first
first come first serve type of deal
all right let's try to finish this up um
you have the right i just want to save
the bishop
but no g2 is not exactly the way to go
because
queen f4
wait wait what don't you see chess king
oh the solution well good
means it's hard no guys repeat just
takes it
why would you give free stuff
yes bishop f3 whoa
f3 cover up your queen cover up your
king
well if queen h5 uh just rook f7 make
sure not to rush it
because now whoops that's gonna be a
draw
any fun stuff just rook f7
any checks just stop it yeah
no i really did like this i think this
was a good puzzle just because
it teaches you how to think
in critically when it comes to these
type of fun positions all right um
i am also going to share the link
for our studies on
uh youtube give me one second
to do that oh no i can't actually
hey i need another second to be able to
do that
uh let me close my chess board
go back on to youtube this is kind of
fun
uh could you explain why you would block
with the rook
um can you ask your question a little
bit more specifically
also so uh this is the link to the study
[Music]
why would you block with rook um
well the thing is i don't want to
i want to be able to eat your queen but
i don't want to give up my rook to eat
your queen
so i'm trying to block i'm trying to
protect my king with my bishop so you
don't have any kind of
weird checks so wherever your queen goes
i'm gonna follow it and i'm gonna eat it
such a cool idea with the bishop
all right everybody i'm gonna take about
five to seven minutes i'll see you
on twitch i'm gonna send our link one
more time
so join us on twitch uh make sure to
follow
subscribe if you haven't subscribed yet
and
have your game ready and so on leachates
and we go live
however your game ready to send it to me
immediately on
most preferably send it on
uh leachat's website so the game that
you have sent the pgn unleashes as a
link
if it's going to be a chess.com it's
going to be a little more hassle so
i'm going to prioritize the um
the lyches ones uh the twitch is going
to be
in about five to seven minutes i just
need to make a
quick switch
all right yeah yeah we're gonna do five
to seven minutes
uh i'll see you all on twitch
so yeah